what sort of work has the foundation
been doing
uh well we've been investing in
something called a social impact bond uh
in three boroughs of london because we
wanted to demonstrate to the nhs it
actually saves lives and saves money by
finding undetected hiv and that's people
living with hiv in the uk that don't
realize they actually have it
how have attitudes change towards hiv
aids we were looking i i don't know if
you remember you're not old enough the
um the gravestones that were falling
over in the 1980s as part of that ad
campaign there was absolute terror and
fear at that stage how have uh attitudes
changed in the last 40 years david
um in the uk attitudes have got better
uh because of a lot of work with the
government did in terms of awareness and
educating people about hiv in other
parts of the world the situation is
still quite heavily stigmatized and
particularly within marginalized parts
of society and marginalized communities
where there's a lot of fear stigma and
discrimination in relation to hiv
back in the 80s when we talked about hiv
there was no hope but now with the
medical advances that we've
developed uh with antiretroviral drugs
uh people live full happy lives with hiv
on just one pill a day and now we have
an injectable treatment which they only
take once a month so we've made
fantastic scientific advances attitudes
are catching up certainly this money
that the government has announced for
opt-out testing is going to reduce a lot
of the stigma around hiv testing because
it's going to become normal in our
health service and starting at aenes in
certain boroughs is a great place but
we'd like to see that rolled out more
into gp surgeries
and aids is i'm guessing i'm writing
saying something that you live with
potentially rather than than die from
now or as you said in the 80s there was
you got the impression that there was no
hope how do we raise awareness for
people who do still um feel that there
should be some stigma around hiv aids
i think we need more role models i think
people like billy porter who people who
stand up and say i'm living with hiv i'm
living a full happy healthy life
and my disease is so well managed that i
actually have zero risk of passing it on
to someone else because when you're on
treatment the news is so positive one
pill a day reduces your viral load to a
point where you cannot pass the virus
onto someone else so treatment is
prevention and
the medications are so well tolerated
now
that compliance is easy because it is
one pill a day it's it's a great story
it's a very very positive news story and
the more people who stand up and just
make themselves uh publicly known that
they're living with hiv that's going to
help a lot to reduce stigma
it would be remiss of me before i let
you go um to not ask how you as a family
have all been coping during the pandemic
and whether you're looking forward to
christmas
uh we've been doing really well thank
you um elton is recovering from his hip
surgery he got a big thumbs up from his
surgeon last week uh and he's throwing
himself into his physio and uh yeah
we're gonna start decorating the house
for christmas soon we're looking forward
to a family christmas
oh that's fantastic it's good to talk to
you thanks for taking the time to join
us we really appreciate it davey thank
you it's a pleasure thank you for having
me